[Music]
u.s inflation hit a three decade high in
october 2021 rising by 6.2 percent
with little evidence that inflation is
moderating each month the inflation
print relies the federal reserve's view
that heightened price levels are but a
transitory phenomenon caused by supply
chain problems while supply-side factors
have played a role the fed also has
contributed importantly to rising
inflation by its continued pursuit of an
ultra easy monetary policy it is done so
by its massive bond purchases and by
keeping interest rates at their zero
bound despite the pickup in inflation
and it's done all of this at a time when
the economy is receiving its largest
peacetime budget stimulus on record
perhaps it's time for the federal
reserve to reconsider its monetary
policy stance
if not it risks causing inflationary
expectations to rise which could take us
further down the path towards another
wage price spiral
how has inflation impacted you please
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei